bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de l'analyse du conflit
ukrainien vous propose une petite
capsule qui va vous donner quelques
informations utiles et quelques clés de
lecture de ce conflit
tout d'abord qu'est-ce que la
géopolitique puisque la partie de
secours et géopolitique
la géopolitique et sait comment la
géographie d'un territoire intervient
dans la prise de décision politique mais
aussi dans la conduite des affaires
internationales rappel indispensable
pour commencer c'est la création de
l'union soviétique en 1917 donc en 1917
et l'âge appel à notre courte histoire
les bolchéviques renverse l'armé blanche
et instaure en union soviétique créé
l'union soviétique et y instaure un
régime de type communiste l'urss c'est
l'union des républiques socialistes
soviétiques au sein de l'urss
on compte différents territoires dont
ukraine l'ukraine au sein de cette urss
reçoit la crimée en cadeau en 1954 et
cette situation perdurera jusqu'à la fin
de la guerre froide et l'éclatement de
l'union soviétique
qu'est ce que la guerre froide
la guerre froide c'est tout simplement
un conflit son ombre c'est pour ça que
c'est la guerre mais qui n'est pas
active donc qui est froide dans une
situation de guerre où on a affaire à
des conflits où il ya des oppositions
armée explicite ou la propagande est
importante c'est à dire que chaque camp
va dénigrer le camp adverse et la
mobilité des relations est basé
simplement sur l'opposition pure et
simple en situation le pet la situation
est inverse puisqu'il n'y a pas de
conflit il n'y a pas d'opposition armée
ni de propagande et on essaye de mettre
en place des mécanismes de coopération
avec les autres acteurs internationaux
dans la situation de la guerre froide
vous voyez que le conflit est bien
présent la propagande est également
maître pas d'opposition direct armée
parce qu'il y a quand même des
oppositions armelle mais sur des
territoires secondaire ou indirectement
les grands blocs des deux grands blocs
s'opposeront et l'a hanté
deux modalités des relations on est sur
le terme de la dissuasion
c'est à dire que les deux camps étant
tellement armés autrement dit chaque
camp possède l'armé nucléaire et donc
peut mettre fin directement et sans
aucune forme de discussion à l'existence
de son adversaire on est sur un mode
désire tant que tu ne tiens pas jeter
rêve est donc on est dans un état de
tension permanent qu'ils ne dégénèrent
en fait jamais et qui se maintient la
guerre froide va pas sonner le visage de
l'europe pendant plus de trois décennies
vous voyez sur cette carte évidemment le
bloc soviétique l'union soviétique
mastodonte territoriale et humain qui
aux portes de l'europe va exercer toute
sa pression parce qu'on appelle le
glacis soviétique le glacis soviétique
ce sont en fait toute une série d'états
qui ont également un régime socialiste
communiste et qui vivent littéralement
sous le joug de moscou dans ce glacis on
va retrouver la pologne la république
démocratique d'allemagne qui n'a rien de
démocratique contrairement à ce que dit
son nom la tchécoslovaquie qui est
encore un état unique contrairement ce
que vous avez pu voir à l'examen ou la
slovaquie et la tchéquie depuis 1993 ont
déclaré leur indépendance
la hongrie la roumanie et la bulgarie
qui termine cette ce chapelet de pays
faisant partie du glacis soviétique qui
est en fait une zone tampon entre le
bloc occidental et le bloc soviétique
du côté européen on retrouve bien sûr
toute une série d'états actuellement
membre de l'union européenne et qu'il
était déjà à l'époque évidemment avec le
plus grand changement évidemment c'est
la république fédérale d'allemagne qui
est scindée de sa partie est puisque la
partie est de la république démocratique
allemande à la chute du mur de berlin
c'est à ce moment là qu'il y à la
réunification allemande
notons également le visage de la
yougoslavie qui éclatera plus tard dans
les années
90 propositions de ces deux grandes
puissances nucléaires conduit à
l'apparition d'un monde bipolaire
d'une part les états unis rassemble
autour d'eux les pays d'europe
occidentale qui sont des démocraties
libérales ou des élections libres sont
organisées régulièrement et permettre
l'alternance politique le régime de la
propriété privée est garantie
l'organisation économique est basé sur
la loi de l'offre et de la demande
c'est à dire une économie de marché
enfin l'ensemble des pays membres de ce
bloc sont réunis au sein d'une alliance
militaire le temps organisation du
traité de l'atlantique nord qui permet
une coopération militaire et une
assistance mutuelle en cas d' attaque
d'un ennemi de l'alliance d'un autre
côté le bloc soviétique
conduit par l'urss rassemblé pays de
l'europe de l'est qui forment son moulin
glacis l'ensemble ces pays sont des
dictatures d'obédience socialiste où le
communisme est de mise
l'économie est totalement planifiée et
conduit à des aberrations qui sur le
terrain se traduit par des famines et
par des magasins vides
l'ensemble des pays sont réunis dans le
pacte de varsovie qui est également une
alliance militaire qui fait face à
l'otan la chute du mur de berlin permet
la réunification allemande en 1989 et
conduit les quatre membres d'union
soviétique deux ans plus tard mettant
fin ainsi à 30 années de guerre froide
en 1991 un camp l'union soviétique mais
le genou à terre l'indépendance de
plusieurs pays dont l'ukraine donne
naissance à un nouveau monde vers de
nouveaux espoirs qui seront dans la
plupart des cas très vite déçu l'europe
voit son visage changé et une voix
composition du paysage politique se met
en place au fil du temps les différents
pays qui faisait partie du glacis
soviétique pologne tchéquie slovaquie
hongrie roumanie bulgarie intégreront
l'union européenne les états baltes
l'estonie la lettonie
et la lituanie qui faisait partie de
l'union soviétique feront de même et
adopteront pour certains l'euro les
ennemis d'hier seront alliés
d'aujourd'hui puisque plusieurs pays du
glacis soviétique intègre l'otan ainsi
que les états balle j'ai donné de
l'histoire
il intègre l'alliance à laquelle ils se
sont opposés pendant plusieurs années